des investissements en hausse des
dépenses de fonctionnement en baisse la
recette budgétaire de valérie pécresse
reste inchangé pour 2018 la région
ile-de-france se fixent notamment comme
objectif principal de devenir la
première métropole écologique d'europe
pour y parvenir plus de 700 millions
d'euros seront consacrés aux
investissements dans les transports avec
la poursuite de la modernisation du
réseau ferroviaire dans le sport la
culture ou encore la ruralité la région
dépenserait également l'an prochain près
de 300 millions d'euros pour tenter de
réduire les fractures territoriales et
sociales entre paris et la banlieue
nous sommes aussi désormais très engagée
dans le développement de la ruralité et
dans le maintien en banlieue de tout ce
qui fait l'attractivité des villes de
banlieue en clair ce que nous voulons
c'est que l'on puisse trouver du travail
près de chez soi vivre en banlieue et
que toute la richesse toute la culture
tout le sport toute l'attractivité ne
soient pas captés par par pai en charge
des lycées la région consacrera
également aux établissements 780
millions d'euros
la formation professionnelle et
l'apprentissage se voient eux dotés
d'une enveloppe de 570 millions d'euros
enfin le déménagement du siège de la
région en banlieue et la réduction des
effectifs permettront d'économiser près
de 40 millions d'euros dans les rangs de
l'opposition les critiques sont
nombreuses pour juger ce troisième
budget de l'ère valérie pécresse le
groupe socialiste évoque notamment une
politique son ambition pour les
franciliens le vote du budget par les
élus est prévu entre le 18 et le 20
décembre prochain